ich freue mich sehr, dass ich die
gelegenheit habe, mit professor
escher nicholas rescher, einem
der berühmtesten zeitgenössischen metal-
musiker, über seine philosophie zu sprechen ich möchte
mich auf drei themen deiner philosophischen arbeit konzentrieren, über die
du
besonders viel geschrieben hast  Das Leben seine Philosophie
Lassen Sie mich das Interview mit einer sehr
metaphysischen Frage beginnen. Warum gibt es
etwas und nicht nichts? Was
wäre Ihre Antwort? Die Antwort auf eine
philosophische Frage besteht oft darin
, sich eingehender mit der Frage
zu befassen und Fragen und Probleme aus der
Ferne aufzuwerfen  Weg zu einer Art
Schluss Wenn wir davon überzeugt sind, dass wir so
etwas wie das Prinzip des
hinreichenden Grundes auch dass jeder
Sachverhalt jeder Zustand der
Dinge eine Erklärung für etwas hat, dann
erscheint es nur einzig plausibel, dass diese
grundlegende Frage, warum etwas
existiert, in der  welt, warum die welt als
solche existiert
, muss sich jetzt ergeben, es ist die, wann man aufs klo geht
Bei dieser Frage ist es eine äußerst
ungewöhnliche und außergewöhnliche Frage,
denn normalerweise, wenn
wir etwas über die Existenz von etwas erklären,
schauen wir auf einen bereits bestehenden Zustand
irgendeiner Art, aus dem sich das Objekt, um das
wir uns Sorgen machen, entwickelt oder
entwickelt hat oder entstanden ist  Die Schwierigkeit
dabei ist, dass alles, was wir
als Prämisse verwenden würden, um
existentiell zu erklären,
warum eine Welt existiert, selbst Teil
dieser Welt ist und in das Problem aufgefressen wird,
so dass die Idee einer Standarderklärung
im Sinne von  Vorbedingungen
der Dinge sind nicht praktikabel, Sie brauchen, es ist
eine sehr außergewöhnliche Frage, und für eine
außergewöhnliche Frage brauchen Sie eine
außergewöhnliche Antwort. Jetzt gibt es zwei
Möglichkeiten, um von dieser einen
zur traditionelleren theologischen Weg voranzukommen, und
Leibniz hat diesen Weg tatsächlich genug genommen  ihm gibt es
ein göttliches Wesen, einen göttlichen Schöpfer, diesen
Schöpfer, das Problem, woher dieser
Schöpfer kommt, wird im
Wesentlichen durch Selbstreferenz beantwortet  In gewisser Hinsicht ist es
ein selbsterzeugtes Wesen, das keiner
weiteren externen Erklärung bedarf, da seine
Erklärung in sich selbst liegt, und
dann haben Sie Material, von dem aus Sie weitermachen können
, weil dieser Schöpfer dann
eine Reihe von Möglichkeiten für
die Entfaltung seiner Kreativität und Anstrengung in Betracht ziehen kann
alle diese alternativen
Möglichkeiten in Betracht zieht und eine davon
zur Aktualisierung auf der Grundlage von im
Wesentlichen evaluativen axialogischen
Arten der Betrachtung auswählt, so hat Linus
eine ziemlich einfache Möglichkeit
, die Frage zu beantworten, warum das
Universum existiert, wenn Sie nicht bereit sind
, einen theologischen Weg zu akzeptieren  Zu dieser
Erklärung
wird das Problem entsprechend
schwieriger, weil Sie jetzt keinen
selbst erzeugten, bereits vorhandenen
Ausgangspunkt haben, von dem aus Sie fortfahren können, um
die Existenz anderer Dinge zu erklären
, was ein Nein ist, da eine sehr sehr
schwierige Reflexionslinie im Gange ist
zu argumentieren, dass es im Bereich der
Tatsachen nicht wirklich in diesem
st  Außerhalb des Bereichs des sachlichen Denkens
wird es jetzt keine Antwort auf
diese Frage geben, da Sie
mit einer Alternative konfrontiert werden, da eine Alternative immer
ist, zu sagen, dass die Frage
illegitim und unangemessen ist. Sie
stellt sich nicht, es ist
kurz gesagt eine metaphysische Frage  Wir, die
rigorosen Philosophen, die dem wissenschaftlichen Standpunkt verpflichtet sind, loswerden,
sollten nicht
einmal fragen, dass dies eine Linie ist, die
man einnehmen kann, und danach natürlich die
Linie, die von den logischen Positivisten
über eine große Tradition der modernen
Philosophie eingenommen wird, die dies möchte  das
metaphysische Projekt insgesamt zu entkräften, würde ich
lieber sagen, einen anderen Weg einzuschlagen, und
es ist ein Weg, der auch von like vorgeschlagen wird
– sagen wir nämlich, sehen Sie, es gibt
wirklich zwei Bereiche der Überlegung, es
gibt den Bereich der Tatsachen und den
Bereich des Werts und
wenn man im faktischen bereich keine
erklärung für die existenz der dinge bekommen
kann, muss man
nun endlich in den evaluativen bereich springen  für
liveness kommt
die idee, dass wert der kern der existenz ist, im rahmen
von als substanzielles argument daher,
weil es Gottes
abwägung der möglichkeiten ist, die ihn dazu bringt,
eine dieser vier realisierungen zu wählen,
was man in dem fall, wo
man will, zu argumentieren hat  Eine rein axiale logische
Erklärung der Existenz ist die viel
schwierigere Idee, dass ein
Prinzip am Werk ist, das dem
Ähnlichkeitsprinzip der Optimalität ähnelt, aber
dass dieses Prinzip selbst bestätigt
, dass die Existenz einer Tatsache
in Bezug auf die Existenz
von Wert erklärt werden muss  indem gezeigt wird, dass diese Tatsache
im Bereich der Bewertungsmöglichkeiten
das Optimum ist und die Frage,
warum das Prinzip der Optimalität gelten
soll,
selbsttragend ist, das heißt, es gilt, weil
es das Beste ist, was die beste Option ist
im Bereich des Möglichen, also ist es
eine Art Metaphysik, die versucht,
über den Wert das Wirkliche aus dem Möglichen
herauszulösen  exzentrisch, aber wenn Sie
sich zutiefst einer Rationalisierung verschrieben haben,
die eine rationale
Erklärung für Dinge ist, die Sie in
diese allgemeine Richtung getrieben haben,
weil es sozusagen das einzige
halb selbstbegründende Spiel in der
Stadt ist, ja, vielen Dank, also meine nächste
Frage  wäre über wahrheit du hast
auch eine theorie entwickelt die wahrheit meine
frage ist was wahrheit ist und wie sollen
wir sie in bezug auf korrespondenz
oder kohärenz definieren was würdest du sagen
ich hätte gerne beides wie
philosophen oft wollen aber finden
Es ist schwierig zu tun Ich denke,
es spricht viel für die
Korrespondenztheorie der Wahrheit, wenn Sie
die Sache unter dem Gesichtspunkt der
definitorischen Erklärungen betrachten, was ist es, zu
behaupten, dass etwas wirklich
und wirklich der
Fall ist  zu sagen, dass das mit
dem übereinstimmt, was Realität ist, ist wie das klassische Prinzip eines ducati oh ich bin, so dass die Übereinstimmung die Übereinstimmung mit dem
tatsächlichen Stand der Dinge ein Schlüssel zum Es ist
Was es bedeutet, etwas als wahr zu beanspruchen,
was ein Wahrheitsanspruch
beinhaltet, ist nun die Schwierigkeit, in der
wir uns befinden, dass für uns
situierte epistemische Listen, wo wir der
einzige Weg zur Wahrheit sind, die
Untersuchung durch einen Prozess ist  zu
versuchen herauszufinden, was die Wahrheit ist, und
an diesem Punkt suchen wir
nach dem Kriterium G der Wahrheit, das heißt zu
sagen, was wir vernünftigerweise in einer epistatischen Position
für wahr halten können, ist
etwas, das wahr sein muss  Nehmen Sie eine kohärente
Histlinie, es ist die Möglichkeit unter
den Möglichkeiten,
die systemisch am besten mit dem übereinstimmt, was
wir mit unserer Erfahrung mit
den Erfahrungsdaten und mit den
Ergebnissen der Untersuchung erreichen können, so dass sich die Kohärenz
zu einem rationalen Gesamtmuster zusammenfügt
von Behauptungen, die
mit dem übereinstimmen, was uns die Beweise zeigen, ist ein
grundsätzlich kohärenter Ansatz die
optimale Möglichkeit
, die Frage zu lösen, was
als wahr anzusehen ist, wann man es annimmt  als
wahr zu dem erkenntnistheoretischen Problem der
Wahrheit der Verifizierung, aber dass, sobald wir
diesen Prozess durchlaufen, das, was wir behaupten
und was wir auf der
Grundlage der Annahme von etwas von der Wahrheit zu behaupten berechtigt sind,
Cohen ist dieser Spinner, dieser Korrespondent, ist die
Ansicht, dass das ist  wirklich, wie die Dinge sind,
also ist es eine Kampf-bei-Ruh-
Theorie, die auf der
Definitionsseite einen entsprechenden Testansatz kombiniert, aber
auf der erkenntnistheoretischen
Bestätigungsseite eine Sicht auf den Kohärenzstandard
als wirksam. Ja,
vielen Dank, also betrifft meine dritte und
letzte Frage
Prozessphilosophie Sie haben viele
Bücher zu diesem Thema geschrieben, daher wäre meine Frage
, was Prozessphilosophie ist und
welche Vorteile sie gegenüber anderen Ansätzen hat.
Können Sie anhand eines Beispiels demonstrieren, dass sie
gut funktioniert, wenn sich
das Problem auf
unsere Haltung bezieht?  werden in das
ontologische Projekt hineinnehmen, was sie versuchen
, eine kohärente Darstellung dessen zu geben, wie die
Realität, in der wir uns befinden, beschaffen ist,
und so weiter  Unter Philosophen war die Tradition des
westlichen Denkens sehr stark
auf die Idee ausgerichtet, dass Dinge
Dinge der Existenz sind,
manchmal als physische Existenz ausgelegt, manchmal
als Adilysmus, manchmal
viel weiter gefasst in diesem
platonischen Sinne, dass sie sowohl ideale
als auch physische Objekte sind, aber das nicht  Auf jeden
Fall muss die Natur des
philosophischen Verständnisses
auf der Grundlage einer Beschäftigung mit
Substanzen, Dingen, Personen als einer Art
von individuellen Dingen, die eine
unabhängige Identität und eine fortwährende
Eigenexistenz haben, das ist die Art
der klassischen Sichtweise, vorgehen
Prozessphilosophen möchte ich sagen, dass es
eine Alternative zu dieser Perspektive gibt, eine
Alternative, die vielleicht auf
Heraklit zurückgeht, mit der Idee, dass
alles im Fluss ist, dass das, was wirklich existiert,
eine Reihe von
Ereignissen ist, die kohärent in Veränderung
oder Veränderung organisiert sind  in Veränderungen, die sie verbinden,
die vier Ströme von vier Sinnlichkeiten schaffen
innerhalb der Dinge des Schemas und dass die
Dinge, an die wir normalerweise denken, auf die
eine oder andere Weise sowohl das Ergebnis als auch
die Manifestation dieser Prozesse sind,
so dass die Vorstellung von
Ereignisketten der Entwicklung usw. die grundlegende Art und Weise ist,
wie Sie wissen  was zu
verstehen ist, was in der Welt vor sich geht, und
dass die Dinge, mit denen wir uns befassen,
wirklich Wellen der Stabilität in einem Meer
von Prozessen sind, um es sehr bildlich zu
sagen, und dass sich unsere Sorge daher von der traditionellen Logik des inhaltlichen Sagens formen lässt  von Gegenstand und
Attribut, sondern dass wir einfach
besser im Griff haben, wie die Dinge in der Welt funktionieren,
wenn wir uns überlegen, was
an Prozessen und
Entwicklungsabläufen vor sich geht, wenn Dinge eine natürliche
systemische Entwicklungsstruktur haben
, wie zum Beispiel der Mensch  Ich meine, ziemlich
typisch ist als eine
Reihe von Prozessstufen zu denken, die auf eine
ganze Reihe von physikalischen und konzeptionellen
Wegen verbunden sind, so dass die Grundeinheit nicht
irgendetwas ist  ein stabiles Element, aber ist dieser Fluss
von Ereignissen, der das, was in der
Welt vor sich geht, in zwei trennbaren, aber dennoch
miteinander
verbundenen Interaktionskombinationen verbindet?
Dinge zu verstehen, Mathematik ist
ein viel besserer Leitfaden als Logik,
weil Logik auf stabilen Identitäten basiert,
die wirklich nicht in
der Welt existieren, dass das, was vor sich geht, viel mehr ist,
diese Angelegenheit viel besser in
den Begriffen der sequentiellen
Entwicklung beschrieben wird als Sie  haben Sie mit
Gleichungen so, wie Sie es gerne hätten, wenn Sie sie
in in in Infinitesimalrechnung haben, wo Sie
funktionale Beziehungen haben, die
Dinge zu in in in
Entwicklungssequenzen verbinden, die nur auf
der systemischen Ebene beschreibend sind. Okay, vielen Dank,
Professor Retro, für dieses sehr
aufschlussreiche Interview  Nun, vielen Dank
für die Gelegenheit, ganz kurz zu behandeln,
wer sehr kompliziert ist, mit sehr
komplizierten Themen